if you've never had sanoo before then
you are missing out because this
delicious Hardy soup is full of flavor
it's perfect for fall and winter and
it's my six soup so I'm going to teach
you guys how to make it I start off by
prepping my root vegetables by cutting
them into 1 Edge cubes next I take my
meat and then I'm going to go ahead and
season it and give it a quick mix to a
large pot I add in oil Sofrito tomato
sauce and saon and then I'm going to go
ahead and add in my pork and my beef
because that takes longest to cook once
the water has juice down and the meat is
soft I add in more water corn planto and
Yuka and then cilantro and kulantro I
let that simmer for about another hour
and then I'm going to add in potatoes
corn and chicken and my key ingredient
which is calabasa a squash and this is
how you get that amazing color this
Hardy soup is so tasty full recipe on
Tony's recipes.com